[Music]
chad's in uh louisiana hey chad how are
you
hey dave how are you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
that's it that's it hey i'm i'm new into
this i'm one week into
um putting all my finances together and
and
and starting the debt free living cool
process
and um my question is is that about five
years ago or
explain a little bit five years ago we
decided to become full-time rvers so we
sold the house in houston
and uh really freed up a lot of money
for us and then
we've been living that lifestyle and
also
we got to the point where i've got
pretty much everything into the
calculation sheet
and i was wondering on my rv
should i refinance that and hopefully
get a lesser
note to add more cash towards my debt
free living
or should i stay on the path of what the
whole thing's explaining to me
by almost six years i'll be debt free
i i would stay on the path and i think
what you're going to find is
that that as you as you plow through
this the momentum is going to pick up
and you're probably going to get out of
that faster than you think
most people that see a six-year plan end
up with about a four-year plan when it's
over because intensity increases
as you get further down into this and
then you so what is your 10-year game
plan on housing are you going to be
rving for the next 10 years
it all depends on the health uh we've
already
figured out that i'm at 55 and no
medications no
illnesses no issues at all hopefully
that
in 10 years what are you living on how
are you how are you just working
remote or what yes sir i'm an
independent rep
and self-employed so i travel
throughout the south central united
states
working with about 40 other reps as
their support
and um so it it doesn't pay me to have a
house
because we're always on the road and you
and your wife
you and your wife yes sir okay yes sir
all right
and you're enjoying this lifestyle so
far
tremendously okay good you don't like it
maybe you can hook up and leave
good yeah well i i think getting that rv
paid off as fast as you possibly can
i'm not sure if it's your baby step six
or not because it's your house
uh you could put it there if you want
how much do you owe on it
uh we're right at 113k yeah
and so if we pull that out of the
equation you're debt-free in a year and
a half
two years okay easy yeah yeah so i think
maybe it's your baby step six as if you
had 110 000
mortgage and you put it over there and
then you work the system that way have
you got a copy of the book the total
money makeover to show you how to do all
this
that's going to be my next step we've
loaded the excel program and my next
step was getting the book because we
just found out about you through my
brother
last week very cool well i'll give you
one uh hold on madison will pick up and
we'll ship you a copy of the total money
makeover as our gift
uh if we can figure out where to ship it
to yeah that's that's gonna be the
hardest part of this